in 1996 pokemon was daring since then
the core pokemon games have mostly stuck
to the pattern established by those
first games developing a sense of
familiarity with steady light iteration
pokemon legends arceus breaks that
iterative pattern attempting to
establish a new foundation while
borrowing bits and pieces from the main
pokemon games to create something new
the result is sometimes messy and
doesn't always work but its distinct
quality set it apart from the core
series and ultimately elevate it
[Music]
though it's a spin-off pokemon legend's
arceus isn't lending the pokemon
trappings to an entirely different set
of mechanics like the mystery dungeon or
stadium series instead this game
reimagines pokemon's core mechanics
finding and catching pokemon and
battling with them within the new
context of exploring vast open spaces
legends arcus takes place long before
the modern games at a time when pokemon
haven't become integrated into daily
life as pets and pack animals there's a
sense that the wilderness here is
dangerous and the villagers treat
pokemon like fearsome wild beasts the
exception to this is the survey corps a
small band of burgeoning scientists
working underneath the local security
forces an ever-present rift in the sky
appears to be driving pokemon berserk
including larger than life sacred
pokemon that are given special reverence
and protection by the local diamond and
pearl tribes as a stranger in a strange
land with no other options you join up
with the survey corps in hopes of
solving the mystery of the rift the
survey course day-to-day work is
building the first pokedex a paper-bound
notebook that compiles all of the
region's accumulated pokemon knowledge
completing your pokedex is always the
goal of pokemon games but it's usually
an incidental secondary goal to
collecting new pokemon in order to train
them for battles in arceus completing
the pokedex is front and center
reintroducing it as a pivotal goal that
connects everything you do including how
you progress through the game though the
process of completing the pokedex
involves similar mechanics to what's
found in the mainline pokemon games
legend's arceus makes it a bit more
involved you can see pokemon wandering
freely around the open environments but
you don't necessarily need to do battle
to engage them you can quietly sneak up
on them and toss a pokeball at them
that's often enough to catch them so you
go through pokeballs quickly dozens in a
single trip building out your collection
the controls behind this binary approach
stealth versus attack capturing versus
initiating a battle can be disorienting
the trigger button is used to toss
whatever you have at the ready and you
toggle between a menu of pokeballs and
kant pokemon using the x button it's
fairly intuitive most of the time
cycling through your arsenal and then
aiming a shot but in the heat of the
moment it's easy to waste a pokeball
when you meant to start a battle or
worse to start a battle when you were
trying to be sneaky
in a mainline pokemon game simply
catching a pokemon would fill out its
pokedex entry but that's not the case
here since you're building the first
pokedex and since the stealth catch
mechanic lends itself to quicker fines
completing a pokedex entry involves
completing a series of tasks a pokedex
sheet will outline tasks often with
multiple tiers like catching a certain
number of pokemon defeating a certain
number and so on once you've completed a
number of these tasks you can turn in
your findings and the pokedex entry is
considered complete it's a remarkably
flexible system that lets you play
pokemon your own way if you love to do
pokemon battles you can make almost all
of your progress just fighting wild
monsters if you'd rather focus on
stealth and barely engage with battles
at all that option is available too
[Applause]
at first i found myself obsessively
checking my pokedex tasks and steering
myself towards min maxing completion but
after a while i found it was much more
enjoyable to just wander the world
stealth catching and battling as i felt
like it and then letting the chips fall
where they may for pokedex completion
unfortunately campaign progress gating
is also gated to completing pokedex
survey results the survey core gives
star rankings that level up as you gain
research points for completing tasks and
filling out pokedex entries new
environments open up as you progress
through the story but between each major
story point you need to rank up to the
next star level that meant for the first
few star ranks i was stuck needing to go
over areas i had already explored
extensively grinding to progress enough
to proceed later in the game once i
gained access to a larger selection of
environments and had access to mounts
that made new areas reachable it was
much easier to progress without feeling
like i had to go back over our previous
area with a fine-tooth comb the battle
system is possibly the most recognizable
aspect from previous pokemon games with
each pokemon in legends arceus only
being able to equip a total of four
moves at a time and all the usual rock
paper scissors elemental matchups intact
but needing to know the finer nuances
into type matchups is de-emphasized in
arceus to the point where moves are just
listed as effective super effective not
very effective and no effect from the
start more recent pokemon games have
included this feature and i appreciate
the help as someone who does not have
the brain space to keep track of every
move match up but it has previously kept
those hints gated behind having a
completed pokedex entry in pokemon
legends arceus that rough edge is sanded
down to be even smoother since you'll
see them all listed right away even the
first time you ever encounter new
pokemon you can also get into an
encounter against multiple pokemon
sometimes just through sheer luck by
starting a battle in the middle of a
crowd of wild creatures these moments
can feel appropriately harrowing since
you can still only have one monster out
at a time and sometimes you'll simply
run into a pokemon far above your level
including red-eyed alpha pokemon that
are larger and more powerful than the
average for their species if you can
catch them they're essentially the apex
predators of their type with a requisite
step bump adding a small but sometimes
vital wrinkle to the battle system is
the option to make any of your attacks
agile or strong an agile attack
sacrifices some strength for speed which
sometimes lets you attack twice before
your opponent can respond conversely a
strong attack will pack some extra punch
but it might slow you down enough that
your opponent can act twice an optional
battle timeline shows when the turns
will occur so you can see how swapping
between agile and strong moves will
affect the turn order this adds an extra
layer of creativity and strategy
especially once you start supplementing
less effective attacks with strong style
because you want to inflict a status
effect or using agile style on a super
effective attack to finish off an
opponent quickly
a series of boss battles called frenzy
battles are also a significant change
from the pokemon norm these large-scale
conflicts tie into the story as you work
with each pokemon's caretaker warden to
learn what kinds of foods they like so
you can make special bombs you then go
into a distinct arena where you have to
dodge the rampaging pokemon's attacks
and hit it with bombs only occasionally
sending out your own pokemon to stun it
long enough that you can rapid fire more
bombs at it saving these beasts by
juggling the priorities of active
dodging looking for open opportunities
to throw and then mixing in traditional
pokemon battles is the most exciting the
series has been in years the wardens and
the leaders of their clans are standout
personalities in legends arceus
introducing a totally new cast of
characters but keeping the focus
relatively small pokemon games often
have a fairly sprawling cast of friends
professors gym leaders elite four
members and the champion and we rarely
get to know any of them particularly
well in legends arceus there are less
than a dozen main characters and we
spend much more time with them getting
to know their personalities and how they
clash with each other there's not a
massive amount of depth to the story and
characters but i still got attached to
these cute anime kids the world is
presented similar to breath of the wild
but this game's distinctly separate
zones don't quite match the sprawling
openness of that zelda game they're
still rather large and it captures that
same sense of wonder but it's not the
same level of impressive technical feat
pokemon legends arceus also seems to be
straining against the technical
limitations of the nintendo switch at
times even among these smaller
environments pieces of world geometry
pop in and out somewhat regularly and
bodies of water in the sky show texture
repetition that's hard not to notice
it's a testament to the quality of the
game that those issues only slightly
detracted from my enjoyment
some of the new ideas in arceus have
rough edges and it's a slow start before
you get access to many environments and
mounts this is an awkward first step and
it was a big adjustment for me as a long
time fan once pokemon legends arceus
finds its stride though it's the most
daring and inventive the series has been
in years breaking apart the state core
and creating something new and exciting
from its pieces
[Music]
[Music]
you